china and us pledge climate change
commitment this is a bbc
news story china and the u.s are
committed to working together with other
countries to
tackling climate change they both agreed
on further specific
actions to reduce emissions a joint
statement on sunday confirmed the joint
statement issued symbolically
at a round table will relieve anyone
concerned about the planet it simply
won't be possible to stabilize uh
climate change unless the superpower
super polluters pull much
harder a recent report said china for
instance must close down
588 coal-fired power plants to meet its
climate pledges
is china heading in the right direction
on coal
no its regional governors have been
building even more coal plants
to stimulate the economy and this goes
to ahead of the trip to shanghai mr
kerry told cnn that china's cooperation
was absolutely critical to battle
climate crisis yes we have big
disagreements with china on some key
issues
absolutely but climate has to stand
alone thoughts let's back
up on climate change sure i was
skeptical because
as a consumer reporter i covered scares
and the
media were hyping the red dye number six
and pesticide residues and caffeine
and everything gives you cancer it just
turned out to be
utter [ __ ] and we're living longer
than ever
climate change comes i was skeptical but
now
a lot of serious scientists do
think this is going to be a problem and
you also have to keep in mind that if
you say it's not a problem no one puts
you on tv
no government gives you a grant so
they're
pressured self-pressured to say there's
a problem
but there does seem to be and our
greenhouse gas gas emissions probably
will make it worse but the last two
points are the key ones
is it a crisis and can we do anything
about it
a crisis is two million kids dying of
dysentery in africa
this isn't a crisis if it is we can
adjust to it as you do around this area
bill dikes holland has been on
two-thirds of the country's been
underwater for years they
with primitive equipment could build it
to keep it out
that makes more sense than doing what
we're doing now which is
pointless subsidies for rich people to
buy electric cars
and pointless subsidies for windmills
that help
al gore and other rich cronies and
all of it's going to make not a width of
difference
it's true as the article says that if
the superpowers got involved and they
really did something
that might reduce our greenhouse gases
but will this happen
as he admits in the paris agreement
all you know that trump rightly scoffed
at
china promised to keep doing what we're
doing now
that's all they promised the only
country that agreed to cut anything was
america
and we only achieved that target because
we switched to
natural gas which pollutes less but it's
still a fossil fuel
and china says it's going to stop
building coal plants but they haven't so
far
we're going to sign an agreement where
we'll obey it and they won't and it
won't accomplish anything
this is bad politics and bad economics
so what changed in your mindset because
you said you were skeptical
and now you're sort of seemed to be a
believer was there a breakthrough moment
an episode
what was it i started reading
serious scientists who were not
knee-jerk
believing every government scare who
said
there is evidence that this may be a
problem
so you do believe that it is a problem
maybe number 15 on the world's list
of problems wow so definitely not in the
top five top ten
no really um i like what
good mother just said good mother just
said we can't hear you good mother just
said
i'll buy the climate to change crap when
the promoters stop buying oceanfront
properties
and good mother you know she's a she's a
bee bag she's always with us here so
but uh what what will come first what
will come first
i want to hear your thoughts on this as
well what's going to come first what
will the world
end with first will it be due to climate
change where we'll all freeze and this
becomes like the snowball effect that
what is it when it happens like no no
there was a phase where
they call it the snowball i think it was
snow once you pull it up the day the
whole
world globe froze it was like an ice it
was frozen
will we die from climate age change
first or a nuclear
full-on insane nuclear war wha what will
be the cause of the world ending
john be a little bit optimistic and
positive thinking here go ahead
will you give me those two choices how
can i be optimistic give me another one
i mean i
maybe maybe show up when you get better
i
i'm a pessimist but i have to look over
my 70 year career
over time people live longer people have
better lives
disaster's predicted but things get
better
to me the biggest threat is ex that
we're going to keep
going into debt and they're going to say
oh look inflation isn't bad
until suddenly the rubber band breaks
and
inflation is crazy and the social media
algorithms are all
feeding us exactly what we believe and
more of it and we're going to be in
warring camps and
we go to war against each other so
you're not worried about the end of the
world that doesn't bother you don't
think that's gonna happen with nuclear
or climate change or any of that
no okay adam any thoughts on this
pretty interesting that number one uh
his number one concern is the debt
the debt crisis because that is a major
concern i don't think that's going to be
what is going to bring down the world
or anything like that i think there's no
doubt that climate change is happening
but just i think to the extent of
what is man's call you know role in this
and i think
something that we should highlight is
the fact that at least
like they say in the article yes we have
big disagreements with china on some key
policies absolutely but climate has to
stand alone
if there i don't trust china as far as i
can throw them i'm sure you're not a fan
of the ccp and anything the hell's going
on there i can't believe anything
they're saying
but having some sort of positive
dialogue is a good sign
with china you know having some
agreements on something
we can disagree on a lot of policies but
at least having some common ground
stop it oh my gosh adam stop it oh my
goodness
so so what what makes you believe
they're going to keep their end of the
bar
i don't believe anything i said that so
what do you do negotiating with someone
that you know they're not going to keep
their under the bar again like how what
is the level of accountability i don't
know like what's going what the iran
deal we have to have some sort of
accounting
what is the level of account no no the
iran deal with china's china is willing
to go to certain measures that maybe us
is not willing to go into
the iran nuclear deal that we have iran
by the way iran so imagine us gives iran
150 billion china gives
iran 400 billion who do you think
they're god so we shouldn't talk to them
i'm not saying not talk to them i'm not
saying don't talk to them i'm talking
okay
so i'm glad you brought that up let's go
through it so here's how i see it i'm
just a basic entrepreneur having
opinions about these kinds of things but
i may be wrong
so let's just say we have climate change
here as an issue
and u.s and china is negotiating about
climate change
okay there is five other issues
i have to process before we go here
this is not my next my number one
before i do anything negotiating with
you china is i need you
just like the rest of the world allow
there to be facebook
in your country allow twitter to be in
your country
allow youtube live to be in your country
allow podcasting to be
in your country allow all our nbc abc
cbs cnn fox news everybody to be in your
country it's like freedom
press so we can see that you are really
being held accountable just like us
because guess what
how tough is it that we wake up every
morning we watch the news
we know [ __ ] about that's going on in
china but you wake up every morning you
watch news and they say look at these
democrats and republicans calling each
other out
these guys are idiots i know exactly
what's going on in u.s it's not fair
competition so before we decide to
negotiate together
mr john representing china i think we
must first agree
to have free press on your end and then
we will gladly
do negotiation with you what do you say
i say that's a good podcast line
your listeners will like that but
screw you we're not going to negotiate
on anything then let's not do it then
i'm not doing it with you either
but it's better to keep talking it's not
about talking i don't mind talking
i'm i'm all about talking i love talking
let's keep doing that
but the talking happens you should add
intellectual property respect
sure that's what i'm saying to you what
i'm going with this is hey the whole
made in china 2025 was about getting all
the trade
trade secrets from u.s and applying it
there every time they invested into
america
companies in america claws on the bottom
you have to give us the intellectual
rights to this in china what the hell
are we talking about here
wait so i think our politicians need to
kind of defend america and protect
america first
and then we're gonna negotiate about all
the other things so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye